this video is brought to you by
expressvpn learn more at expressvpn calm
/ wisecrack you know that this is good
acting you know that this is bad acting
I don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating good I have doubts bad oh hi
mark but what the heck is this here we
see Nic Cage in 1988 film vampires kiss
a performance that spawned 20 million
memes in a film with otherwise normal
performances and cinematography Kage
spoke like this the works not just gonna
go away over it never just ran like this
and ate a live cockroach like this by
the way we just covered this insanely
kinda awesome movie on our movie podcast
show me the meaning we're actually doing
a full month of Nicolas Cage film so
check out the links in the description
to join us on this journey into the cage
e abyss movies like vampire's kiss
provides some clue as to why Nic Cage is
acting career is one of the most
disputed of any leading Hollywood star
[Music]
some people love the guy Ethan Hawke
calls him the only actor to evolve the
craft since marlon brando while david
lynch dubbed him the jazz musician of
acting now I know what you're thinking
this Nic Cage
this Nick Cage the Nick Cage that's
motivation for this scene was my whole
motivation here was to try to see how
big I could get my eyes just to freak
her out yep
that Nic Cage in recent years Cage has
become just as well known for the
ridiculous memes he inspires as the
roles he plays leaving us movie lovers a
wisecrack really and truly befuddled so
today in this wisecrack edition we're
asking Nicolas Cage deep or dumb let's
investigate who is Nic Cage anyway
nephew of director Francis Ford Coppola
Cage is arguably one of the hardest
working actors in Hollywood with over 73
films and his repertoire the guy's also
pretty bad with money which may have
something to do with his apparent
inability to turn down any paying gig
he's an unusual Hollywood leading man
having appeared in stinkers weirdly
great indie films big action films and
everything in between his refusal to be
typecast also makes him difficult to
wrap your head around he's basically
half leading man half character actor to
understand Nicolas Cage and this we need
to put him in the broader context of
film performance history when the first
silent narrative film started being made
they drew largely from the most popular
performance entertainment of the time
theater and particularly the genres of
melodrama and vaudeville both forms
called for large sweeping gestures that
could be as easily understood in the
balcony as in the front row this
tradition was coupled with the
limitations of the silent film genre
which had zero verbal communication
other than this fancy type set actors
had only their faces and their bodies to
work with that meant a lot of wide eyes
ugly crying and berserko gestures it
wasn't realistic and it didn't try to be
then in the late 1920s talkie films with
synchronized sound started becoming
technologically and commercially viable
suddenly actors were forced to rethink
their entire craft a crisis best
encapsulated by this moment in singin in
the rain in which a famous silent film
actor clumsily attempts to translate his
craft into the new era
sound I love you I love you it's
somebody get paid for writing that
dialogue change was slow and movies of
the 1930s typically show stars
expressing a heightened reality that
harkens back to their silent film roots
you ain't mad at me men are you no I
ain't mad at you importantly just a few
years earlier America had been
introduced to the groundbreaking
techniques of Constantin Stanislavski
a Russian acting coach whose ideas about
realism would eventually be turned into
method acting basically Stanislavski and
method acting attempt to help actors
channel emotional truth from within Hey
as these techniques became adapted from
theater to film actors began turning
their characters into fully rounded
people and sometimes briefly living as
those people like Daniel day-lewis who
spent the entire production of my left
foot in a wheelchair these antics were
eventually packaged as publicity gold
which is why Leo almost froze to death
and why Jared Leto mailed out dead pig
heads anyway methods emphasis on realism
coupled with the enhanced realism
offered by sound film congealed in the
40s and 50s and swept Hollywood actors
like Marlon Brando became famous for
disappearing into a character while
there have certainly been ripples of
other directing and acting styles such
as the dementedly over-the-top campy
performance is seen in John Waters films
nobody
there's remained an overwhelming
emphasis on realism as the goal of
acting for film we typically award
Oscars to actors who have disappeared
into their roles frequently while
portraying real people which is all well
and good except when we become dogmatic
about it cinema scholar Carol Zucker
argues that the idea that acting for
film should adhere to a standard of
gestural and psychological
verisimilitude ie realness or trueness
suggests a limited vision of performance
basically what if the dominance of
realism in acting has left us with a
narrow vision of what acting can be is
the reason Nic Cage performances looks
so weird because he falls out
this view that's the persuasive argument
made by author Lin Sahib in national
treasure her book long love letter to
the actor giver counts the way Nic Cage
originally embraced method acting even
having two teeth removed for his role as
the injured veteran in 1984 s birdie
but cage quickly tired of the style thus
began the truly cagey in search for a
form of acting that went beyond in 1990
he told American film I wanted to put
back into acting a more surreal or
experimental style that wasn't totally
run by literalism which seemed like a
dead end
cage considers vampire's kiss to have
been the laboratory for the new ideas he
was toying with a low stakes indie
setting where he could experiment play
and recite his a sorry we really loved
that scene vampire's kiss we start to
see the Nic Cage we've come to know and
me there you are he makes bold daring
choices that take advantage of all
aspects of his physicality including
some patently goofy facial expressions
while we're accustomed to seeing some of
this broad style acting in every era of
screwball comedy Paige would go on to
employ fearless Lee whether he's working
in melodrama action or horror he is
unapologetically performative while that
quality proves confusing for the viewer
in naturalistic films like vampires kiss
it tends to work really well in movies
that push the limits of reality movies
set in surreal worlds that can
accommodate his bold choices take cages
bombastic performance in moonstruck
which is fitting for a film preoccupied
with the dramatics of opera asrani the
long estranged brother of Teresa's
fiance Johnny Cage expresses a
volatility that is captivating to watch
over 30 years later in Mandy cage gives
an unrestrained heavy metal performance
only appropriate for an LSD fuelled film
featuring a sword boner similarly in the
dreamworld of David Lynch's wild at
heart
cages outrageous brain
dashing Elvis crooning sailor feels
right at home this is a snakeskin jacket
and for me it's similar my individuality
and my belief in personal freedom cages
dialed up style can work provided the
filmmaker and the other actors are in on
it
cages outrageous antics lead many a
critic to deem him out of control or
over-the-top but understanding how he
approaches his craft kinda changes
everything
cage is incredibly thoughtful and
incredibly well versed in the craft of
acting some of his most famously
ridiculous moments are planned out move
by move by move take the famous alphabet
recitation of which cage says every one
of those moves each Handclap hip thrust
pout and holler was carefully thought
and planned out at other times cage
takes inspiration from kabuki a Japanese
avant-garde performance art that
combines acting dancing and singing with
extreme stylisation that's probably
where cages tendency to ad-lib made up
lyrics comes from best scene in this
drunken interlude in leaving Las Vegas
the clink lion king of the room argues
that what cage calls his Western kabuki
style and its appreciation for the hyper
performative is the reason he tends to
adopt a different voice for every
character he plays a said
the bunny back in the box for his own
part cage says his vocal experimentation
has been an attempt to use his voice and
in almost heavy metal or operatic or
baroque way have you ever been dragged
to the sidewalk and beat until you
passed
indeed it doesn't get more heavy-metal
than his screaming scenes in Mandy pages
insane attention to the details of body
movements is the reason his character's
an adaptation feels so persuasively
different cage plays twin brothers who
represent the two sides of screenwriter
Charlie Kaufman's personality Charlie is
a neurotic chronic over-thinker obsessed
with making genuine art while Donald is
the charismatic Hollywood sellout
fittingly they move like two entirely
different people an effect Cage says he
created by adjusting his spine for
Charlie's rigid and controlled movements
cage hunched over and tensed up while he
straightened his back and loosened up to
portray the more go with the flow Donald
at other points cage draws inspiration
from German Expressionism commonly
viewed as the first real film movement
which explored the horrors of post-world
War one life in Germany through highly
emotional subjective storytelling
dreamlike horror films defined the genre
depicting nightmarish worlds filled with
twisted terrifying villains these films
left a lasting impact on the film world
influencing genres like film noir horror
and even graphic novels like Sin City
Nic Cage
isn't one to miss out on the fun in
interviews he's described watching
classic German expressionist films like
Nosferatu and metropolis as a kid and
described the way certain distinct Han
motions like this famous gesture and
moonstruck were inspired by those films
at other times he's modeled the
characters physical attributes off
characters from German expressionist
films other times he'll take things to a
more mystical level take his role as
Johnny Blaze in Ghost Rider a
performance that was widely panned give
describes how Cage adopted what he calls
Nova shamanism in which he integrated
afro-caribbean techniques and sewed
thousand-year-old
gyptian artifacts into his clothing he
also prepared by painting his face white
and black like a voodoo priest all these
techniques were meant to trick him into
thinking he's a character from another
dimension with special powers now keep
in mind this was all in preparation for
this role rather than phoning in his
superhero turn Paige decided to push the
boundaries of what is comfortable for
his oscar-winning performance and
leaving Las Vegas Cage studied cinemas
most convincing alcoholics and even
hired a drunk actor to hang out with him
in his trailer as a constant student of
the craft he takes on roles not because
they'll improve his reputation clearly
[Applause]
instead he tries radically new genres
roles and pulls from new influences
whether he's channeling ancient vampires
or even more ancient shamans Nicolas
Cage defiantly refuses to conform to
realism drawing into question why that's
even a benchmark for our understanding
of good acting we don't fault the song
yellow submarine for unrealistically
depicting the aquatic life modernist
authors like Virginia Woolf are deemed
revolutionary for the way they're highly
stylized novels depict life in the
abstract reading unreliable timelines
and dreamlike narratives meanwhile
musicians like Arnold Schoenberg and
John Cage are considered geniuses for
breaking every rule of normal music
making so why do we consider a departure
from realism to be an explicitly bad
thing only when it comes to acting well
we'll venture a guess film with its
close-ups and point of view shots is
arguably the most intimate art form when
we so closely identify with a central
character we naturally expect the
performer to behave approximately the
way that we would part of why Nick Cage
can be so maddening to watch is that he
specifically refuses to do just that I
think you better pulled the trigger
because I don't yeah he's also generally
working with people who don't ascribe to
his acting philosophy like if a death
metal singer subbed in at his local
church choir his wild reactions and
bug-eyed expressions confuse our
expectations they also make her
particularly ridiculous moments that in
a meme which erases the context of the
film may
his performance seemed ridiculous but
what if there are actual merits to is
out there performance style compared
Nicolas Cage's Peter in vampire's kiss
to Christian Bale's charismatic and
murderous Patrick Bateman in American
Psycho while both films are poking fun
at the corporate yuppie culture of the
80's bales Bateman has become an iconic
antihero who is weirdly revered and
perversely admired for his highly
specific brand of social status
obsessiveness look at that subtle
off-white coloring a tasteful thickness
of it oh my god it even has a watermark
in comparison cages Peter is so
inaccessible so clearly performative
that he runs no risk of becoming
sympathetic to the audience
still there's a reason we're talking
about Nic Cage and not say Chris Pratt's
acting style it's compelling it's
different its controversial and
ultimately it's subjective you have
every right to consider this ridiculous
or to consider it totally awesome either
way we'd argue that with a few more Nick
cages
Hollywood might just be a lot more
interesting you don't have to be
president of your local Nick Cage fan
club to construe value and what he's
doing in fact you can straight-up find
him absurd no matter what you got to
admit he's pretty interesting so what do
you think isn't it Cage deep or dumb let
us know what you think in the comments
and hey if you value your security and
secrecy on the internet then I really
recommend this video sponsored
expressvpn if you don't know a VPN is a
Virtual Private Network allows you to
surf the web safely and privately by
routing your connection through a server
and hiding your online action that means
you can do things like access videos
that might not be available in your
country or have security when logging
into those sketchy public Wi-Fi hotspots
seriously with all the sketchy stuff
going down on the web getting a VPN has
been a big source of relief for me plus
you don't want the feds or your FBI
agent Andrae knowing you've streamed
every episode of honey boo boo so take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
free by going to expressvpn comm slash
wisecracks or clicking the link in the
description try expressvpn today for
less than seven dollars a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee again that's
expr ESS VPN comm slash wisecrack thanks
for watching guys
[Music]